The Joe Rogan Experience why isn't there
this Groundswell I mean outside of the
obvious thing of financial interests of
major corporations corrupting our
political system but like why is there
not kind of people saying this is insane
because of the financial issue it's it's
100 because of that because they've
co-opted the media and they the media
doesn't report on all these things you
know the media doesn't report on so many
things that are bad for you because it's
bad for their interests well let me ask
you this and we'll be right back to the
Jim Gaffigan show in a minute I'm here
with uh Joseph Reagan Rogan no let me
ask you this so all right so Sam bankman
freed just got off of
that's totally not corrupt no by the way
he deserves to be free do you think he
doesn't go back doing meth and hanging
out with that that little floozy in that
house that you had with 40 other people
and banging each other occasionally when
he would when he would be in court in a
suit I would be like Ah that's so cute
he's got a suit on
it's kind of like you know a boy at a
bar mitz versus confirmation right it's
just like ah look at him like a real man
but all right let me ask you this feds
drop campaign contributions charged
against Sam bankman freed but is that
all his charges about everything are
there other charges are still available
or is he a free man now I think they
said he had to get a haircut which is
really weird okay Federal prosecutors
are dropping campaign Finance violation
charges against alleged crypto crook Sam
bankman freed over a legal snafu in his
extradition from the Bahamas to the U.S
still faces 12 other charges in the case
of five more of those counts are still
in question because they were added
after he was extradited
it seems to me one of the fix is in well
let me ask you this all right so a
logical any comedian would look at that
and go all right so
somebody in the Justice Department was
like he donated a lot to our people
let's make this go away but here's
here's a question I have so
there is that uh there and there there
that level of corruption but do you look
at that level of corruption and see it
as equal to what
Trump has been repeatedly busted as do
you see those as equal or do you see
like
um that as because you know like I I
wonder if like to me it's like
you know like like the indictments
against Trump I'm like it's gonna keep
going right they're gonna there's gonna
be more things whereas like this is
vague corruption I'm not justifying it
but like I feel like some people see
this as totally equal you think both
sides are equally bad
is that you would have to go over the
case right because the way it's been
described to me and the way the CEO was
looking at it you're saying that this is
fraud this is like straight out fraud
it's financial fraud and they were
they were taking uh clients money and
using it in a way that they were not
supposed to they were funneling it off
to Almeida he was not being honest about
his connections to that I don't know all
the absolute specifics of the case but
the way it's been described to me is
that there is not enough regulation in
cryptocurrency and that these people are
allowed to do some really shady [__] and
that these people took it to the the to
the far end of this right and you know
they were making insane amounts of money
and they were doing amphetamines and
they were hanging out and having this
polyamorous lifestyle with these bunch
of super nerds but you shouldn't you
shouldn't go to jail for that not yet
not for banging each other no I think
that's fun I'm happy that they get to
live like that like yeah socially
awkward weirdos all of a sudden they're
super rich if they were doing it above
ball above ground rather everything was
cool I would be celebrating them I'd be
like Yay look at these they won but a
lot of people lost a lot of money and
you know there was also they were they
were being exposed by competitors by
binance and then it turns out that
binance is [__] too and they're up
their ass with a microscope and they
might have all sorts of problems with
fraud and all sorts of other things that
are being lobbied against them or or
level against them I don't know you know
it's it's a lot of complicated Financial
stuff that's outside of my realm of
understanding yeah it is interesting
because the basic premise again I know
nothing about crypto but isn't the basic
premise of crypto is like there's no
regulations that's yeah this currency is
outside of it's not tied to the dollar
it's you know it's uh you know uh it's
there's an independence there whereas so
you can't compare that to Martha Stewart
going to jail for insider trading right
yeah
I I mean the Martha Stewart thing is
interesting because
Congress does what she did all the time
that I mean they get access to
information
tons of times I mean and it's not just a
Democrat thing everybody points to Nancy
Pelosi it's a republican it's like
literally 100 black and white I mean
excuse me red and blue it's like across
the board yeah they're all doing it and
it's just something that I think
everyone does that's there they they
understand like bills that are going to
be passed and then they immediately
start buying stocks and they've always
done that and it's one of the reasons
why they want to be Congressman in the
first place
that's one of the reasons why they go in
uh with a certain income and leave
millionaires just not just millionaires
like insanely Rich hundreds of millions
of dollars for uh you know six figure
salaries
yeah look Nancy Pelosi is a better stock
Trader than both Warren Buffett and
George Soros
her her husband is uh an investment guy
yeah or he was an investment well he is
when he works with her right like she
knows things he bets he you know he
places the the stock options and we
right that's also I mean I remember like
the all the the Senators that pulled out
right like Richard Byrd and Kelly
loffler and all these guys right when
the pandemic
uh and they they they they they remove
they sold their stocks and then they
said everything's fine right so it's
like some of it is selling stocks it's
not necessarily even buying sure yeah
but yeah but it's having information
that would allow you to make and not
just an educated guess but you know
what's going to happen you know what's
going to happen and you know that
because of these decisions that are
being passed that these companies are
going to become far more valuable
because they've got certain deals and
then you bet on that and that's what it
is
it's it's inside of trading we all know
it is